c'est un travail titanesque qui doit
être réalisé c'est le constat depuis
plusieurs années maintenant de tous les
organismes internationaux qui traitent
la question migratoire sur le sol
nigérien des organismes tels que le
Haut-commissariat aurait fugué ou encore
l'OIM cédant l'immense région désertique
d'Agadez plus de 660 000 km² que doivent
se concentrer les efforts des forces
conjointes de la CEDEAO car chaque année
c'est plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
personnes qui tentent la traversée du
désert de cette région pour rejoindre en
majorité en ce moment surtout la
frontière algérienne pour ensuite tenter
de rejoindre les côtes méditerranéennes
sur ce chemin sur ce parcours et bien
souvent les obstacles sont bien trop
importants pour les personnes sur les
voies de la migration les plus chanceux
sont ramenés au centre de transit
d'Agadez
pour que
ce refoulement respecte la dignité parce
qu'il y a c'est très dur c'est
douloureux parce que l'indéchelle ne
reçoit pas simplement les pays de la CD
la donne 5 nationalités que l'on a
retrouvé dans ce centre y compris des
gens qui sont passés par d'autres
frontières au moment de le refouler on
les renvoie au Niger il faut prendre en
charge psychologiquement aussi ces
personnes et la prise en charge
psychologique c'est aussi une des
dimensions sur lesquels on ne prépare
beaucoup attention mais qui doit être
aussi réalisé c'est ça qui explique
parfois les mouvements du monde des
migrants selon le Yem c'est plus de 80%
des personnes présentes dans le centre
de transit d'Agadez qui ont été
précédemment refoulé de la frontière
algérienne la route de l'Algérie et
celle qui est privilégiée aujourd'hui
par les migrants du fait de la remonter
ces derniers mois des tensions sur le
territoire libyen